what did you think of Guillermo del
Toro's cameo in season four Bill Hader
wasn't sure he'd be able to act but the
moment he'd named the character after
Toro that was it and did you know that
Paul Rudd had a bit of a say in the
series soundtrack this is behind the
scenes on Barry Guillermo del Toro could
hardly believe it when he was cast he'd
sent Bill Hader a funny text asking
could I be in Barry without expecting
anything to come out of it these sorts
of requests came in on television shows
all the time but it's rare for the
writer to find the right role for them
and even rarer for the writers to name
the characters after them it's an honor
to finally meet you Toro which Bill said
was his way of telling Guillermo well
now you've got to do it bill was
pleasantly surprised by Guillermo's
acting abilities but that didn't stop
Guillermo from trying to do what he does
best giving Bill tips on how to direct
fortunately bill is always willing to
take advice even from his old buddy Paul
Rudd did you notice the song that was
playing in season 4 episode 2 when lawn
stepped into the theater we can hear a
cover of the song Desperado by the
Langley schools music project which was
originally uploaded as a YouTube video
back in 2013. this version of the song
somehow wound up on Paul Rudd's radar
and when Bill Hader was struggling to
find a song that would fit into this
scene Paul was quick to suggest oh you
should get that choir to sing Desperado
Bill took his advice and a classic
moment was born upon watching the scene
back Bill said that the song was so
funny and even thanked Paul for his
contribution if one thing on season 4 is
for sure it's that it was definitely a
group effort Barry gets to live his
dream in season four not his dream of
subscribing to our Channel unfortunately
although you can do that by clicking on
that red button right now Bill Hader
didn't think it would be interesting to
see Barry on the run after getting out
of prison in real time instead he
remembered a Daydream Barry had back in
season one about he and Sally and a boy
taking a family picture and so I was
like well maybe that's what he wants
this is why episode 5 suddenly jumps
forward eight years and why we see them
on the lamb in costume and all all
playing a character Sarah Goldberg
decided that Sally would speak in her
own voice in the home absolutely
I see that but put on an accent out of
the house well then we're just gonna
keep doing what we're doing explaining
that she's really decided she's going to
give the performance of her career even
if there's no one there to witness it
Sally's accent isn't the only thing
that's changed after the time Jump part
of being on the Run involves changing
your hair too which is why Sarah
Goldberg had to wear a dark wig she was
impressed by just how far it went
towards making her look like a
completely different person but said
that the itch factor is so vivid she
wasn't alone in having to change her
hair for season four either Henry
Winkler was asked to grow out his hair
and beard but apparently forgot about
reshoots before getting a haircut hair
extensions were added to makeup for this
as well as a fake beard that Henry was
absolutely terrified about since one of
my deepest saddest nightmares is to have
something pasted on my face fortunately
he was happy with how the beard turned
out although this is far from the
scariest thing that's happened on set
the Taylor Chase has to be one of our
favorite moments on the show the
motorcycle chase from season 3 episode 6
wasn't even shot like a conventional
action scene instead Bill wanted to just
let the camera sit back and look at what
was happening for the tone of the show
it needed to be strange and a little off
the whole scene was first put together
using computer animation although stun
performers and dummies were used when it
came time to shoot the scene stunt
coordinator Wade Allen tried to
encourage Bill Hader to get on a
motorcycle himself but Bill was far too
scared Wade was like I think we should
have some stuff of you on the motorcycle
and I'm like I'm not Tom Cruise I have
no interest instead he drove a car that
was occasionally pulled on a rig the
Taylor chase ends with one of the
motorcycles getting hit by a truck this
would obviously be too dangerous for a
stunt person to perform and so they
replaced the actor with a dummy before
driving a truck straight into it
and for some reason that just made the
crew like so happy to get the shot where
he actually flies through Barry's
windshield this was done in two takes
one with Bill Hader in the truck
pretending to react to it while another
take actually got the dummy flying
through without Bill inside and action
everything from there was done old
school in camera merely by layering the
takes together but when it came to that
one tattoo in season four they needed to
feel more real which a fuke's tattoos
were your favorite Stephen Root is
particularly fond of crosshairs on the
back of his neck explaining that it was
endemic of this character that he would
have a Target right there on his neck
makeup artist Leo Corey Castellano had
each of the tattoos specially made and
would take around 70 minutes a day
applying them to poor Stephen but he's
pretty good at sitting still for things
like that by this point Steven once
played a Klingon on Star Trek that
required three and a half hours worth of
makeup he says that he likes to meditate
during that time which is probably a
better way of coping than writing an
entire series out of his frustrations
the way Bill did you may already know
what it's like to be good at something
you don't enjoy that was Bill hader's
experience on SNL I've had a weird few
years he consistently got rave reviews
on the show co-head writer Seth Meyers
even praised bill for the way that he
taught people to love what he did rather
than try to do what they liked and yet
Bill wasn't built for the live action of
the show he would have full-blown panic
attacks in the bathroom before shows and
what's worse was that he felt like he
had to keep going because do you know
how many people would kill for this this
eventually inspired Bill to create Barry
although he wasn't necessarily thinking
that he was going to star in it at first
you may be surprised to hear that Barry
wasn't created as an easy vehicle for
Bill Hader to star in after his
experience on SNL Bill really didn't
picture himself working in front of the
camera again he pitched Barry with the
condition that he be allowed to direct
it and it was only later that he
reluctantly agreed oh I guess I'll play
Barry bill was especially hesitant to
take on the part of a Hitman because he
has a massive fear of guns but his
vision definitely adds a lot to the show
Henry Winkler praised bill for his
ability to go back and forth between
directing and starring although he says
that Bill had an annoying habit of
mouthing everyone's lines because he'd
written them
[Applause]
you were great so on the subject of
Henry Winkler nobody was sadder than him
to see season three delayed by the
pandemic you may have been disappointed
to wait three years to find out what was
next for your favorite characters but
Henry has a special connection to the
show while filming his final scene for
season two Henry realized that he
recognized the set they'd been working
on and that it was the same stage where
he'd spent nine years shooting Happy
Days oh it ain't no trick to gift at
this point the entire cast and crew
became distracted as Henry went around
pointing out where different sets and
locations had been built as cool as that
must have been for him we love the image
of nohoa Hank reminiscing about Happy
Days NoHo Hank is the breakout star of
Barry he's a surprisingly fun character
for a leader in the check-in mob but did
you know that a lot of the personality
was actually Anthony Kerrigan's idea he
said that the character was originally
supposed to be attentive just wants to
make sure that everything is fixed but
when he read the role I just saw him as
this really bright and sunny and cheery
kind of guy this approach was so great
that even though NoHo Hank was supposed
to die in the series pilot he managed to
stick around right up to the final
season as showrunner Alec Berg pointed
out we'd be insane to kill that guy he's
so funny and this is far from the only
way the actors have affected the series
like did you notice anything interesting
about Lindsay in season three if you pay
close attention you can see that she's
visibly pregnant although this is never
brought up in dialogue and is only ever
hinted at when she seems to be
experiencing pregnancy cravings for
vignettes otherwise this pregnancy seems
mostly to hint at the passage of time
and as a way to write in Jesse Hodge's
real-life pregnancy with her and her
husband Beck Bennett's first child she
gave birth sometime in March 2022 it's
hard for us to say if Lindsay was meant
to become a mother around the same time
with the series remaining silent on the
matter which one of these behind the
scenes details were you the most
surprised by and is there anything else
we may not have mentioned we'd love to
hear your thoughts so don't forget to
make them heard in the comments section
down below
foreign